eSports competition is grueling and can
wear down even the best pro players but
fans don't only want to watch players
compete they want to care about them too
I mean my goal I wanted people to
recognize me I wanted people to know
like hey this that's nadeshot dude that
that's nature and know where was the
balance between high level competitor
and internet personality better realized
than in a young kid from Chicago
it's a [ __ ] done his name is Matthew
nadeshot hey and he's one of eSports
biggest stars this is his story one of
the most influential players in the
history of competitive Call of Duty
actually started off hating the game the
first experience I had with call of duty
was cod 2 and that was when I first got
my xbox 360 I put the game in and I
literally got spawn shop for the next
five minutes and I never played it out
to them I absolutely hated it because of
that one experience but though he didn't
fall in love with cod - he loved gaming
so much that his mom made him get a job
at McDonald's just to get him away from
the screen I think when any parent sees
their child doing something that's
really out of the ordinary you know
that's gonna raise a lot of red flags so
I can imagine what they thought about it
and I think that's the main reason why
my mom made me get a job because she was
worried that I was just gonna waste my
life away behind my my computer screen
like eight hours a day eight to 10 hours
a day we would just grind search and
destroy public playlists because that
was what was fun for us seeking greater
competition
nadeshot and his friends went to game
balance a platform that would land him
his first big break there he met murk
and the two were approached by optic
nerve during modern warfare - nerve
offered the two gamers a chance to build
an optic roster since 2009 optic gaming
were committed to creating video content
while they were going back to the
organization's roots by fielding a
competitive roster the entertainment
side of the industry was their focus
even at this early point in the teams
history there were hints that the route
to popularity didn't have to rely on
tournament results fans could be earned
online and introduced to competition
while eSports fans could find more to
like above these competitors
on YouTube and hex would eventually
bring nadeshot around to the optic way
of thinking content daily whenever
possible was the path to a dedicated
following I meant he was a lot younger
but very pleasant just smiles all around
fun got to be around it to talk to and
that was the first time I actually I
never met I think a pro player before so
I was kind of just taken back like what
what is this relationship dynamic though
they managed to defeat heavyweights team
envyus a Dallas optic finished 8th and
while they still received strong fan
support not long after the event hex
called nadeshot and told him that the
rest of the team wanted him gone at the
time Hector convinced made to continue
with content creation and to stay on
with optic in that role in nature he saw
a rare combination even though he wasn't
naturally comfortable in front of a
camera he was a strong competitor but
also someone approachable that fans
could identify with nade told his fans
that he was no longer with the team and
although he said it was a voluntary move
he later admitted that it had been a
crushing experience in terms of
competition it wasn't clear when or even
if made would return but he threw
himself into the business of content
creation despite still having school and
a part-time job anytime that I was at
home I was playing call of duty or
working on content production for my
youtube channel or my livestream that
drive showed heck's that his investment
in nade might still pay off and when the
competitive team needed a replacement
for rambo at MLG Dallas 2011 made shot
got the call and obviously I haven't
played a while so I'm curious to see
what happens after helping the team
place third nadeshot went back to
creating content but hex could see the
competitive fire still burning in
nadeshot size and created a second optic
team called optic nation for him to run
though that team had limited competitive
success HEC saw that made shots content
was doing something different
nadeshot understood it too as he
consistently produced content that
bridged the gap between the eSports and
gaming audiences by offering a glimpse
into his personal life
this gameplay is gonna wrap up I kick
the [ __ ] out of my brother and he's
older than me he was pretty pissed
because I got kyle korver
and the Chicago Bulls of Derrick Rose
you too huh [ __ ] you doing hey guys it's
Nate shot and I'm doing a vlog for my
iPad that I actually got for my birthday
and my grandparents got it for me I hope
you guys can't hear these dogs in the
background because they are loud as hell
alright go ahead with his subscriber
base on YouTube continuing to grow
nadeshot announced that he had finally
quit his job at McDonald's
he was all-in on Call of Duty in June
2011
optic nation placed 6th at MLG Columbus
while the main optic gaming squad took
first but nade saw a shot at glory with
another team and briefly joined Envy for
MLG Anaheim and MLG rally after a couple
of events with envy nadeshot finally had
another chance on optics main roster at
the biggest Call of Duty event yet
caught XP 2011 featuring a million
dollar prize pool and a post tournament
performance by Kanye West
it was Activision's first big step into
figuring out caught esports the
tournament may not have had the most
competitive field and it featured modern
warfare 3 a game that wasn't even out
yet but with nadeshot optic 1 again
raising questions about why he was
sidelined when both his skill and
popularity could be better harnessed by
the organization but he stepped back
down restarted optic nation and waited
he waited for over a year during which
he played with a number of mixed teams
none of which had wins at any major
event however uneventful 2012 was in
Nate shots career it was the year in
which he would suffer his most
significant loss if you follow me or
anybody else that my mom actually passed
away at the age of 47 on Saturday night
she died in her sleep that's kind of a
gruesome detail but just want to let you
guys know that I am truly am thankful
for all the support that you've shown me
on Twitter in all my social media
outlets like Facebook Nate Schatz mother
Christina had sometimes criticizes
gaming but in time came to support his
eSports dream I think she would approve
now for sure
I think things have kind of taken off to
a point where she wouldn't have a choice
at this point I mean just the things
I've been able to do for my family and
the things that I've been able to do for
myself in my career I think she would
completely understand it
while Nate shots 2012 had been
tumultuous optik had been experiencing
one of its most successful periods in
Call of Duty dominating modern warfare 3
with up-and-coming star scum but
nadeshot wasn't satisfied with watching
the team success from the sidelines so
he convinced hex and the team to add him
as a starter in place of Rambo I
convinced them to let me back on the
team so like it was it was my time to
shine I had all this pressure on my
shoulders because nobody really agreed
with the roster move they did not want
to see Rambo off the team but for me
like this was me trying to come into my
own with nadeshot in the lineup optic
headed to UMG Chicago for the first ever
LAN event on the recently released Call
of Duty Black Ops 2 we were either gonna
be so incredibly successful and shock
the world or I was gonna be like the
laughingstock of like the competitive
community in spite of the pressure
nadeshot rose to the occasion and the
team found themselves in the grand
finals against an ache sled complexity
that was the biggest rivalry for us to
DX always kicked optics ass for whatever
reason he just always beat us he was
just talking so much [ __ ] before this
match even started like we're sitting on
main stage and this dude is just doing
what he does best and he's trying to get
into everybody's head and I was just so
focused on win the mats that I really
wasn't you know getting in on it but
nadeshot and optic would have the last
laugh this time and the fallout from
their triumph got a little heated comes
down to this and we see this shot get
staying up big he gets the Killa
creamsicles Odie's at 3 on 3 situation
now big time we're looking through that
next mix of the Cal Americans throughout
and huge play big that makes a big hill
and now it's come picks up on ax and
it's a 1v2 and then
TV stuck in a cordon is going to be able
to this and their position
nadeshot and aches already had a history
but this incident would escalate their
rivalry to the next level this is like a
cringy and embarrassing video but it
likes set off like the entirety of the
success that Paul did he had man I'm
cringing watching myself but this was
just like a moment that I'll never
forget
as 2013 began nadeshot finally signed
with redbull after over a year of
speculation regarding a deal probably
the most humbling experience of my life
for me this is kind of something that
was a dream come true it marked not just
a landmark moment in maids career but
for Call of Duty eSports as a whole
although optic managed to beat aches and
complexity again at the Call of Duty
Championship a disappointing third place
finish marked the beginning of a major
'less slump for the team in 2013 but
optic was changing they added a gaming
house in Chicago and continued to grow
in popularity despite their lack of
first-place finishes
even when the results weren't there the
content was made shot now living in a
team house and fully immersed in call of
duty took a moment to reflect on how big
this opportunity really was and this is
something that I've always really I've
always wanted and you know my mom my
momma my mom never really saw it going
anywhere
and she really worried about me she
really worried for me if if this was
gonna work out if this was gonna if I
was kind of screwing my own life up by
quitting school but I always saw a
school of something like it's always
gonna be there and it's always gonna be
my backup plan so the fact that all this
has worked out so far and it's the
growth has continued I really do I
really do appreciate you guys a few
months later J cap replaced murk and the
team finished second at the MLG Fall
Invitational optics best placement since
UMG Chicago with aches playing foil to
made shots hopes in a back break
come back all the pressures on shake a
pure explain it perfectly don't engage
make him go for the plant now X knows he
needs to kill Izzy too late in
transition against the carrier j-cap oh
you didn't get away the ninja j-cap here
it's gonna come down to one final place
o picks up the kill face with the one v
two clutch complexity winning their
fourth straight slay him know about that
one bounced up creamed sixes 1 V 3 with
a 1 V 2 2013 had shown optic that the
demands of both competition and content
creation could take their toll on
players that were unprepared but
nadeshot had always been able to satisfy
both sides of that equation still hex
acknowledged that the situation must
have been frustrating 2014 would be the
year of Call of Duty ghosts a polarizing
game within the eSports scene that
ultimately led to a roster shake-up on
optic the team would keep an aide and
scum but add clay stir and proofy
however despite the lineup changes it
would end up being a year optic fans
would prefer to forget although the two
had arguments in the past an incident
early in the year saw nadeshot and scum
butt heads with scum p-- actually
issuing an ultimatum to the team get rid
of nade or he would leave and go to team
envyus he basically thought that I was
the reason why we can win
he just wasn't a fan of me he didn't
like me anymore nadeshot actually went
to hex and offered to step down saying
that sculpt was the better player and
deserved the spot but given the way
stump had approached the situation hex
decided to keep Nate Shaw it would work
out as scum quickly asked to come back
after a disappointing start to the year
the team again managed a third place
finish at the call of duty championship
and once again they lost a close
important series to complexity that is a
600 finished work up laxity morale
wasn't great as the year continued but
nadeshot wasn't giving up invited to
participate at the MLG X Games
Invitational the team had an important
chance to get on the board against some
of their biggest rivals going into that
term in AI I thought that we were we
could either place top three or we were
gonna get dead last it was
Invitational Tournament there was eight
teams you know practicing and Scrimm
stress prior to the event were very up
in the air in terms of the results we it
was just really inconsistent the former
complexity roster that included aches
signed with Evil Geniuses right before
the event and truthfully I'm a pretty
realistic person a little bit of a
pessimist so I was thinking like the
worst was coming and then all of a
sudden we came out of the gate swinging
and froofy and nadeshot a tattoo up to
against critic and karma they chucked us
win that come fight against crimsix
ocularly comma in a one versus two bomb
is believed that way that's so she's
right next to a player picks up the kill
that's gonna extend him same one that
comma in a one versus two proofy NHL
still up from Tacoma he's in that be
site and I bombers down most importantly
he's running out of time he knows that
he had done make sure extend it to 901
and he's getting [ __ ] up nature with a
big defensive stand they have those
cubes like they just need to try way
sometime they don't get a clean up
another Kofi there's one way put you
behind as well as that them hopefully
kept someone on a I'm with 20 seconds
left optic gaming have done what won't
be impossible they have taken down Fiji
after defeating eg optic defeated team
caliber in the finals to earn a gold map
good about to get cleaned up from behind
yeah Nate shots a peacock you gotta let
him fly sometimes man he gets those
kills their god Nate oh the air he's got
to get the kill cujo's gotta find clay
sir clays gonna look hey glad it off the
game
there was no prize pool and it was an
invitational tournament but optic had
found a victory in the middle of a
difficult competitive season I don't
know I feel like I'm about to tear up
it's my first time well G event that I
ever won I'm so happy that I wonder with
these guys ever since I watched halo 2
as a young kid on MLG I dreamed about
winning an MLG event and for this to
finally happen plus a gold medal at the
X Games it's it's literally a dream come
true
sadly this would be the high point for
the teams here and as the team continued
to struggle nadeshot increasingly became
the subject of controversy as the team
went to a red bull sponsored training
camp
nadeshot and skunk were already looking
for a replacement for proofy the answer
would be crimsix and he wanted to add
formal to the team so clay ster 2 was
released on paper this roster was poised
to take the 2015 Call of Duty advanced
warfare season by storm the fresh game
was a boon for nadeshot the team got off
to a strong start
they earned first at UM Jiu Orlando and
the regular season of the MLG pro league
season 1 they won the playoffs too and
went on to dominate the cod championship
in a regional finals but while the team
was doing well nade felt like his play
was deteriorating his reactions weren't
enough to carry him through matches and
when optic finished 7th at Cod champs
after their hot start made shot knew it
would be his last event I felt like my
passion to win just wasn't high enough
to continue to compete at this level and
so to give you guys kind of a mindset of
what's been going through my head I just
felt like I was playing to not lose I
wasn't really playing to win so that I
wouldn't have to hear about losing the
repercussions of it on Twitter and on my
youtube channel and the week after I was
just so immensely afraid of the fact
that nobody would want to kind of watch
my streams or my videos because I didn't
have that role in optic gaming anymore
and and
that is something that definitely kind
of hindered me from making that decision
a little sooner three years of streaming
YouTube content and competition had
pushed him to his limit but the comments
blaming him for the team's woes became
overwhelming I'm a pretty self-conscious
person and with all these people being
so hyper critical about the way that I
play and my role in that team it got to
me man and I've got pretty thick skin
but I just didn't want to be the
scapegoat anymore in hindsight it's
surprising that he managed to juggle all
these responsibilities for as long as he
did and given the demands of eSports
competition today it's unlikely that
we'll ever see it happen at his level
again you might see players saying hey I
don't want to be full-blown competition
and dabble a little bit or I'll be
full-blown content and maybe not you
can't just dabble in competition right
you have to really really focus so I
think that fork in the road is gonna
cause decisions but for the players that
can maintain both more and more power to
it but it's tough it is tough to do
nadeshot has since created his own
organization 100 thieves in 2017 it was
revealed that 100 thieves had secured a
spot in the newly franchised NA LCS and
had backing from Dan Gilbert the owner
of the Cleveland Cavaliers in their
first na LCS split 100 thieves placed
first in the regular season and may shot
was with the team every step of the way
I'm so happy to be a part of these guys
as careers and our team is awesome and I
want to scream it from the mountaintops
call of duty gave him his first big
break but it didn't define him and even
now as he cheers on the team that he
both manages and owns it's obvious that
one of eSports biggest stars is still
that kid from Chicago that's it
you too I'll see you [ __ ] later
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button
[Music]